I was just doing stand-up one night at
The Improv and David was in the audience
and then he talked to me after he's like
oh you should come to YouTube and I was
like I can't do YouTube on my 43 and he
was like oh why not like just go do it I
really really owe him my life he was
like oh how much money do you need to
make a month and I was like I need like
five thousand dollars a month I said oh
you you can make 5 000 a month and so
then like I made like a very very bad
first YouTube video with him and then
maybe like
four months later I was making like 35
000 a month really I called my ex-wife
she's like I need money for
me first and I was like oh I got it I
got it no problem she's like wow and I
was like oh I'm making like 35 000 a
month and there was just like a long
silence on the end of the phone and she
was like what it felt so good